Welcome to the
launch of our course
on shaping the future of work.
Together, over the
next seven weeks,
we'll explore how to expand
the number of good jobs,
career opportunities,
and workplaces
that help us all realize our
dreams, our aspirations we
have for work.
For our family lives
and for building
sustainable successful
enterprises,
and for our societies.
But before we talk
about that, let's talk
about some of the
difficulties we've
experienced in the
last week or so.
I want to begin with the
statement of solidarity
for our colleagues in
Europe and in Asia,
in light of the terrible
tragedies that have occurred
in Brussels and in Pakistan.
Today, we are all
sharing our concern
that there have been
over the past 18
months, 75 bombings
in over 20 countries,
killing over 1,300 people.
We think about the grief and the
pain that so many nationalities
and religions and people
of different cultures
all over the world
have been experiencing.
And we are with them together.
My fellow of course team
members here at MIT and I
feel profoundly sad at
yet, more acts of violence.
We condemn them.
We are committed to addressing
the causes of violence
in our societies and
in our workplaces,
and to doing everything
we can to help
resolve these differences before
they devolve into terrorism.
Above all, this course
rests on the principle
of respect for diversity in
our world, in our work places.
We had planned to
show a bit later
in the course, a 20 minute
video interview with Mary Rowe,
one of the world's leaders
in managing diversity
and workplace conflicts.
Mary outlines the
ways that we can
address these
tensions and the anger
that they show in our society,
and that sometimes do spill
over to our places of work.
But given the events
in Europe and Asia
and other parts of
the world, we'll
post that interview this
week so we can start
discussing these issues now.
So we invite you to
watch Mary's interview
and use it in the
discussion forum
to comment on how issues
of diversity, inclusion,
and the management
of inequities can
be addressed in your workplace
and in your job experiences.
We can design a
better future as we
help each other shape this
aspect of our workplaces
in a positive way.
I invite you also to
get started by sampling
the rich array of other videos
that we have posted this week.
We have welcoming comments from
national and internationally
renowned leaders from
all over the world.
The US secretary of
labor, Tom Perez,
the director general of
the International Labor
Organization, Guy Ryder.
The secretary treasurer
of America's largest union
federation, Liz Schuler.
And our course team's human
resource management expert,
Lee Dyer.
We include this
diversity of voices
to show how all of
these communities
need to work together to
shape the future of work
for you and for all the parties
that have a stake in it.
And don't miss our three
minute animated video
summarizing 3,000 years
of the history of work.
I think you'll enjoy it.
Then we move on to other
videos and readings
that discuss the challenges
and exciting opportunities,
innovations occurring
in our workplaces today.
These set the stage for a much
more in-depth conversation
about these issues
in the weeks ahead.
We also note in your
discussion forum
that you already
started, that some of you
are concerned about
how the issues of jobs
and the future of work
are being discussed
in the presidential campaign
in the United States.
Some of you have lamented
that yes, they talk about jobs
but don't have a vision
for the future of work.
Well, maybe it's our
job to bring our voices
into these conversations as
we will try to do, and really
lay out a vision for
what work could be,
what the real needs
of workers are,
what the real needs of
businesses are today.
So maybe we can add our
voices to this discussion.
So welcome, join us.
Look forward to having
you engage with us
and helping to see if we can use
our collective efforts to shape
the future of work.